I was really impressed by how many job
interviews I landed after I added the
certification to my portfolio even
though I was new to the world of devops
I finally decided to join Macquarie
group as a Java devops engineer and now
I am earning 40 more than my previous
job I am full Hilario and I am an I.T
professional I was born and brought up
in Manila Philippines
I have spent my whole life here I
started my It Journey with Accenture
three years ago I joined there as a
cloud architect there I worked with AWS
and Azure Technologies while working
there I became interested with devops I
was anyway looking for higher paying job
and devops seemed the right career
choice I applied to several companies
but didn't get any callbacks I already
knew about cloud computing so I decided
to upskill myself with a course in
devops to enhance my overall profile
simply learn offered a flexible payment
system
I was able to split the course fee so I
decided to go with the postgraduate
programming devops in collaboration with
Caltech ctme during my interview at
Macquarie I was asked about git commands
kubernetes and other Technologies I was
able to answer with full confidence
because I had learned these Technologies
during the course I was hired
immediately with a 40 salary height I
also learned Technologies like ansible
terraform and darker I am using this
Technologies on a daily basis and I have
been able to make some contributions at
work my overall experience with simpler
was positive the course was divided into
modules
and we had assignments for each module I
really like the Capstone project I am
really happy that I took this course it
didn't only boost my career but also my
confidence
foreign